yes you read that title correctly rest
in peace
budget laptops because apple has finally
added
the final piece of the puzzle to the
10.2 inch ipad
and they've crafted the absolute perfect
budget laptop replacement whether you're
trying to work from home for your job
or you need something for your kids to
use for doing school work from home
this newly updated ipad is the perfect
solution
that beats virtually every chromebook
option out there
and even a lot of budget laptops so in
this video
i'm gonna explain what changed this year
for apple's budget ipad
and why it's such a big deal in terms of
being such a great laptop replacement
and then i'm gonna go into all of the
advantages compared to just buying a
cheap laptop or
chromebook this new ipad is apple's 8th
generation ipad
and for the last two years ever since
the 6th gen model
it came packed with the a10 fusion chip
which was pretty decent
but the lack of performance was visible
in many different areas
first off you could tell that apps
loaded a bit slower
and navigation was sometimes a bit
glitchy with the processor lagging
slightly behind
in terms of what you want to do with
your tablet web browsing would be
noticeably slower compared to other
higher end ipads
and for apps that require a bit more
performance
this ipad just wouldn't cut it kids love
ipads because of the massive ios app
store that's filled with
every type of game out there from casual
games to ones that teenagers would enjoy
like call of duty for example but for
those more demanding games
the basic ipad just didn't have enough
power
but now apple has finally given us what
we wanted
and they've upgraded the processor to
the a12 chip
which is much more powerful in terms of
both processor performance
and graphics performance as you can see
in these benchmark tests
so now everything from the highest end
games we could find
and performance apps like photo or video
editing apps
all the way to web browsing and the apps
you would use for working from home
like word excel zoom or business apps
they all work perfectly on the new 2020
budget ipad
thanks to that new a12 chip now as far
as everything else like the display and
the design
it really hasn't changed since last year
but it's honestly not too bad for a
budget tablet
and the only thing it really lacked was
better performance
which it now finally has so you're
probably thinking
that's awesome that's great but it still
can't replace a laptop or a chromebook
but i'm here to tell you that it can and
it works even
better than you think here's why earlier
this year
apple released the long-awaited cursor
support feature
for the ipad and shortly after that
logitech came out with the combo touch
keyboard case
for the budget ipad so let me explain
why it's such a game changer
it comes with a very solid case which
gives it incredible drop protection
so you don't have to worry about your
kids cracking the display
but there's also the bottom portion that
connects magnetically
to the ipad smart connector which
basically creates a hard-wired
connection
that powers the built-in keyboard and
built-in trackpad
so there are absolutely no batteries or
dealing with a bluetooth connection
and by the way logitech is the only
third-party company
that supports the smart connector and
it's the main reason why i recommend
this keyboard case
over any other option you could find on
amazon
the reason for that is because it gives
you a very reliable typing experience
without any lag every keystroke is
registered
perfectly unlike some bluetooth
keyboards out there
it also makes the trackpad experience
excellent
with every swipe getting registered just
like you'd expect on
a laptop not only that but this keyboard
case
is the only one for the ipad that
supports all of the same gestures that
you get with an
actual macbook so you can swipe up with
three fingers to get to the home page
swipe left and right to quickly switch
between apps
and do things like zoom into a photo or
excel spreadsheet
by pinching with two fingers you're
basically getting a one thousand dollar
macbook air
experience with a 329 dollar ipad
combined with the 150 logitech combo
touch keyboard case
and the crazy part is that this ipad
is now more powerful than the macbook
air
in terms of processor performance and on
top of that
the new macbook air is known for having
overheating issues
and very loud fan noise even while doing
simple things
like browsing the web the ipad doesn't
even have
a fan at all and it manages to stay
perfectly cool
thanks to the efficient a12 mobile chip
so you can quite literally
surf the web use common apps and do most
of the things you can do with a macbook
air
on this budget ipad thanks to that
keyboard case
but getting back to the main point of
this video let's talk about budget
laptops and chromebooks
and why it just doesn't make sense to
buy one of those compared to
this ipad so let's say you walk into
your local best buy and you tell them
you need a computer for your child
to do school work from home and you have
a budget of around six hundred dollars
they're either going to point you to a
chromebook which relies on the web
browser to get work done
since actual app support is incredibly
limited
or they'll point you to a cheap windows
laptop
which has fairly low specs and very
often
doesn't have great build quality both of
those options are probably going to work
just fine
and you'll be able to surf the web join
in on zoom calls for school or business
and
other things like that but on top of
already being able to do
all of those things with that keyboard
case the ipad has a couple of
very important advantages first off it's
much more
portable than those laptops and
chromebooks especially since you can
take the keyboard portion off
and use it as a tablet so when your work
is done
you can relax on the couch and watch
some youtube or netflix
with a small and lightweight tablet
instead of a full laptop
and on top of that the ipad gets apple
pencil support
which has the reputation of being one of
the best note-taking and drawing
experiences you can get on any tablet
and then if you're getting an ipad for
your kids they have access to the
massive ios app store full of
every type of game which all run
perfectly well
thanks to the new chip and the very
optimized ipados software
now that's something you can't say for
budget laptops
since you need much more performance to
get a decent gaming experience
for windows games and the game selection
for chromebooks
is basically non-existent compared to
apple's ios app store
now if you don't care about games apple
also has a massive library of
basically every app you can imagine
whether it's for business or
anything else and on top of that apple's
ipads are known for running very
reliably for years
not slowing down like other cheap
tablets do
and they don't suffer from crashes and
error messages
like a lot of cheap windows laptops do
and the best part about ipads is that
they get software update support for
years apple's latest ipad os 14 was just
released
and it still supports every ipad since
the ipad air 2
which was released all the way back in
2014
so that's going to be seven full years
of updates before it loses support
next year in september and that's also
part of the reason why ipads hold their
value so well
in fact i opened up the facebook
marketplace and i found
two ipad air 2s selling for 225
to 250 and those ipads are from 2014.
you won't find an android tablet or a
budget windows laptop
from that year that still gets software
updates
and still runs decently well it just
doesn't happen
and they lose their value like crazy but
ipads on the other hand
hold their value so well because they
run reliably
for many many years for example i still
have an
old ipad mini 2 from 2013 and even
though it doesn't support the latest
ipad os 14
or even last year's ipedos 13 it still
runs fine for basic things like browsing
the web and watching youtube videos
which is really impressive the point i'm
trying to make is that if you choose the
ipad route
you know you're going to get reliable
performance and software updates for
many
years in the logitech combo keyboard
case turns it into a laptop
that can achieve basically everything a
budget laptop or chromebook can
and thanks to the new chip the 10.2 inch
ipad can run basically any app or
game on the massive ios app store
without any
issues and you can even do some video or
photo editing
which you can't really do that well on
any budget laptop
which also have the reputation of
slowing down drastically within a few
years
now there are some advantages with going
with a budget laptop
like having a more open os that allows
for better multitasking and easier file
transferring than on the ipad
but those two positives aren't enough to
beat the overall better experience
and value of the ipad so with all of
that said
i can say with absolute certainty that
the 10.2 inch ipad is now the best bang
for the buck ipad
we've ever seen thanks to apple adding
that incredibly powerful
a12 chip and thanks to the new logitech
combo keyboard case
i can also say that for the first time
ever the ipad is now by far
a much better choice than any budget
laptop or chromebook out there
for working from home or for school work
thanks to the excellent long-term
reliability
and all of the extra tablet features you
get with it
so to finish off this review good job
apple
for finally giving the budget ipad a
very powerful chip
and adding cursor support because of
those two things
you finally reached your goal of the
ipad becoming
an excellent laptop replacement at a
very reasonable price
and it couldn't have happened at a more
perfect time
now that more people are in need of
personal computers
for working and doing schoolwork from
home so if you're as convinced as i
am that the ipad is a much better choice
compared to buying a budget laptop
you'll find links to the 10.2 inch ipad
and that logitech keyboard case
down in the video description below and
if this review was helpful
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video